the race for a vaccine has been the
biological equivalent of the moonshot
one and a half million deaths a global
economy on its knees
a virus that came from the blue but in
labs around the world scientists
deconstructed its genetic code
designed more than 200 possible vaccines
and got the first through clinical
trials
in less than a year robin shattuck one
of britain's leading vaccine hunters
says it's been a triumph the last year
has been
intense incredibly exciting
invigorating but at this stage
it's been amazing that actually
vaccines are coming through in a way
that we didn't anticipate and a level of
efficacy
that was way higher than anybody
predicted so
it's an amazing success story the world
health organization announced on the 9th
of january that a new virus had emerged
in china
two days later the chinese authorities
released the virus's genetic code
within a month the biotech company
moderna announced it had a prototype
vaccine
in april oxford scientists began the
first clinical trials of their candidate
and in july pfizer and biontech were the
first to show their vaccine triggered a
good immune response
by the end of november all three
vaccines had closed in on the finishing
line
with pfizer emerging as the first to win
approval
the vaccines are proving far more
effective than most optimistic
scientists had been expecting
even just a few months ago preventing 50
percent of all covered cases would have
been seen as a good result
it's much closer to 95 even in elderly
patients who have weakened
immune systems and that could have a lot
to do with the genetic technology they
use
for the very first time the payoff
if it worked was phenomenal but they
could only have been developed with
volunteers like lydia
stepping forward to test them here was
an opportunity
to participate in something really
meaningful
at such a dark time my mum lives in
north wales
and i haven't been able to hug her i've
seen her once
since march in a socially distanced way
when the rules permitted
but i haven't been able to hug her since
since since lockdown and oh i'm crying
because i miss my mum
the world health organization's special
envoy says it's a new
chapter in medicine this will change
the face of of disease management
not just in humans but in other species
it's it's wonderful
when you actually feel a big advance
happening while you're on the job sort
of thing very special
now comes the dash for doses to protect
almost
8 billion people on the planet only then
will science really have defeated the
virus
thomas more sky news